there's a lot of tragedy in the media
these days and I get it things are tough
tragedy also sells seek it's not sexy to
tell somebody that the American Dream is
alive and well if you're just willing to
step out and work for it that would be
lame only a loser would say that and I'm
just the guy to do it stay tuned
I'm here in Torrance California where
Cory and Gracie took his once humble
garage dojo and transformed it into this
world flasher Jitsu Academy and all too
common story here in the u.s. today
upstarts start small and then they grow
big here in the land of opportunity but
it's a story that's Henner Gracie you
could call him the ambassador of gracie
jiu-jitsu originally my grandfather
grandmaster andrew gracie learned the
japanese style of jiu-jitsu from his
older brother Carlos the challenge was
my grandfather was so physically frail
and so weak compared to his brothers
that he couldn't utilize the Japanese
techniques with any great effectiveness
so he spent several years modifying the
techniques to accommodate his frail
physique and those modifications
incorporating more leverage better
timing patience those modifications are
what gave birth to what we now know as
Brazilian jiu-jitsu or Gracie jiu-jitsu
he became so confident in his modified
version of the art that he began
conducting challenge matches in Brazil
where he would literally find all the
toughest martial artists could find and
challenge them to no rules fights to
prove that even as small as he was his
techniques what allowed him to prevail
against a much larger stronger opponent
he was very successful so my father and
his brothers my uncles were essentially
born doing this stuff as early as they
can remember
grew up learning gracie jiu-jitsu and
once my father earned his black belt he
realized that our system of self-defense
was far too effective to be confined
only to brazil and he he had this dream
of making it available to the rest of
the world but he realized in order to
make that happen he had to come to the
land of opportunity and so hurry and
pack his bags for the good old US of A
we brought not all these devastating
fighting techniques but a killer like
all upstarts things began small for E
and ran is humble Academy out of his
garage at first offering free trial
classes for first-timers along with
additional free classes for getting
others to join word-of-mouth traveled
fast but even faster when people saw the
Gracie's actually fight unlike
traditional martial artists who lived in
the world metaphysical theory hoary and
his brothers put their money where their
beautifully stashed now
were as they continued the tradition of
the Gracie challenge the Gracie's were
unstoppable which gave [ __ ] Ian an idea
it gave [ __ ] Ian a wonderful awful idea
Gracie challenge matches and the garage
fights were very effective on a local
level but my father realized that in
order to showcase the effectiveness of
Gracie jiu-jitsu to the world it had to
be put on television so that's what
inspired him to create the Ultimate
Fighting Championship
he chose his younger brother hoist to
represent our families fighting system
boys went in there defeated those Giants
winning three out of the first four
ufc's and the rest was history the UFC
was a huge success the whole world
wanted to learn gracie jiu-jitsu and
that's what allowed the Gracie's to
expand their empire to everything that
you see here
seriously brother I told you they'll
come in the locker bowls running just
yeah no no no please not only that but
Gracie combatives became the official
combat system of the United States Army
along with that the Gracie's now on
their own online school at Gracie
University calm they became successful
not through government grants or
subsidies no tax breaks or incentives
the Gracie's became successful by
innovating martial arts like the world
had never seen and they provided a
vastly superior product what was being
sold in traditional martial arts schools
across the United States not only that
but the Gracie's now help people live
long fruitful lives just like the Gracie
family through their Gracie diet which
you can learn about at Gracie diet.com
see it wasn't Wall Street her
politicians who called the shots but
every kid who've been bullied woman
who'd been victimized or self-respecting
men who made great use it through a wild
success if that's not free enterprise I
don't know what is the traditional
martial arts that were being practiced
in America when my father arrived here
we're very popular and thanks to guys
like Bruce Lee and others but the
challenge was that although the the arts
looked very pretty on camera and they
were fun to practice they didn't
effectively prepare the student for all
the eventualities of a real street fight
so just to show you what a great product
and service gracious who provides henna
has offered to showcase some of his
techniques using these human dummy I've
addressed appropriately
unless you're auditioning for Rocky
three okay now we're talking now you're
ready to roll way down please speak this
way head that way of course the fight
start standing up punch isn't wrong
please get out of hand grab the people
grab onto each other and unless
somebody's knocked out while they're
standing the fight goes to the ground
and we would love to end up on top
except for one thing if the bad guys
know you're heavier and stronger they're
gonna end up on top of you
worst case scenario
listen not that it's not good but that
Delhi may or may not work we actually
take this person off of you without the
mind on someone else to save your life
if you had to get out and only you can
get you out
how would you listen that can make your
situation worse you tickle him it's
nothing punch me in the face and you
have more serious problem why am i right
where I'm sure this is here's the deal
when the person is holding you down
penny you're grabbing they could punch
him he could have you in a headlock that
could children and eventually we teach
all of those variations the simplest the
most common ones that they're grabbing
and hitting you by the throat so would
you do this situation if this hand come
under grab my vision would call monkey
grip which is no thumb this hand grabs
the back of my elbow on the same arm and
your foot tap my foot by tucking my arm
and leg on the same side
I had no base points over here when I
need them I can't post my hand up now
very slowly bridge me on both feet
thrust your hips up and roll me in that
direction and go all the way pop boom
and now you're out of here
and so there you have it
cake thanks to a family with an idea and
if everyone's willing to work hard
Gracie jiu-jitsu is now part of the
American dream and you can apply gracie
jiu-jitsu to your American Dream same
principles patients must be patient with
your opportunity okay timing you will
see the opportunity when you see it use
the proper timing to them to technique
where you leverage it properly
that's gracious you're in - I'm keeping
it real are you mocking sound like
you're doing an impression of
penetration in his own academy